KASPER LUND: So I'm Kasper.
I'm here to give
you some insights
into what we're doing
with Dart for mobile
and how we feel like we
can actually change mobile
for the better.
So when we talk about mobile,
it's probably no surprise
that it's the two
devices on the left there
that has our attention.
You already now have
ways of running Dart code
in that context.
What we're looking
at here is a way
of giving you the
flexibility to run
Dart in a more
native-like setting
and still provide a lot of
the nice values and features
that you know from Dart.
So why is it that people
want to use Dart on mobile?
Well, Dart is a modern and
light technology stack,
and our focus on
developer productivity
seems to fit really well
in the mobile space.
The one thing that I also
mentioned in the keynote
is that code sharing across
multiple client apps,
or perhaps different
variants of the same app,
seems to be something that's
really compelling, especially
for large teams
that struggle when
they have to deliver
three different variants
of the same app.
So imagine you have a very
complicated application,
like a to-do sample
here, and you
want to deliver
three versions of it,
three different UIs all
running the same core model.
It's a little bit painful to
have to write that core model
in Java, in Objective C,
and maybe some C++ code
in the middle.
So it'd be nice to
be able to just take
that part of your business
logic, dump it into Dart,
and just skin it for the
different kind of UIs.
What you see on the left
is the Android version.
What you see on the
right is the iOS version.
And in both cases--
this is actually
a running sample I can show
you too, if you want to see it.
But in both cases, they're
using native widgets,
so it feels like
it's a native app.
It's just that all of the
content that we show here,
it just comes from
a Dart application.
So it's a fairly simple setup.
So you have a UI for iOS
and a UI for Android.
Let's just focus on those two.
The client, or the
command line version,
is not that interesting
in this case.
And underneath that, you
have your application model
written in Dart.
And in this case,
the application model
is fairly simple,
but there are lots
of cases where it's
really, really complicated,
and it's really core
parts of your offering
that will fit in there.
To actually make this
application model fly
on these devices,
we have to talk
about what it means to
have a Dart runtime there.
So the Dart runtime is the
part of the stack that actually
runs your Dart applications.
And already now we have
a really great offering
for Android, but
for iOS, because
of some of the restrictions
on that platform,
we've had to do a little
bit of engineering
to try to come up with a
new solution in that space.
So let's look a little
bit at that runtime system
and then dive into what Fletch
is and what it will become.
So Fletch is a Dart
runtime for mobile.
It's targeting the iOS
space where we have
sort of a hole in our offering.
There's no great way of
running Dart code on iOS today,
and that's what we're trying
to plot with this thing.
It's a new thing, so
it's not a product yet.
It's not something you can pick
down from GitHub today and use
for building real things.
But it's something
we're productizing
over the next quarters.
So what is it really?
It's a small and
elegant runtime system.
It supports on-the-fly
program changes
to keep the right level of
productivity for you guys.
So that means that
we'll allow you
to basically change the
program while it's executing
on a mobile device, so to
make that hole edit, compile,
refresh cycle really,
really smooth.
It actually also runs an
iOS through interpretation.
And the key selling
point here is
that this is a way for you guys
to write Dart code that runs
on iOS in a mobile setting.
So some of the sort
of key characteristics
are kind of interesting here.
It's designed to be very
light, interactive in a sense,
and also very concurrent.
So the lightness
is-- I mean, it's
hard to measure that
with just one metric.
I'll throw out some numbers
here to give you an indication
of where we're going with this.
First of all, we made
it so that it start up
really, really quickly, even
on these mobile devices,
so that adding Dart support
to your mobile application
doesn't really cost you on
the startup of your app.
So we're looking at
around 2 milliseconds
for starting and shutting down
a small Dart, like a Hello World
thing.
But that's really sort
of probably as low
as we can almost get.
We might be able to
make it twice as fast.
But the way we've done this
is to really double down
on the implementations
of the snapshots
and use the fact that the
snapshots that the Fletch
system runs have byte
codes in there that
are ready to be interpreted
from the first millisecond.
So there's no parsing
or scanning overhead.
So it's a very simple
thing that way.
It also has a low
memory overhead.
Right now it's around
200K in binary size.
That means that it doesn't
add a lot of dead weight
to your application to just
throw it in there, even if you
only want to add a few methods
of Dart code to your system.
We feel like it's
really important for us
to stay in that space
so that we can work out
as an add-on to an existing app.
So even if we're not
providing a ton of value yet,
the cost of including it
is not sort of prohibitive.
So we're focusing on something
very small, very lightweight,
and very simple.
The interactive part
is kind of interesting.
We heard a question
during the panel
today that the one
missing thing in Dart
is the ability to update
code and work with it
in a sort of more
interactive and live way.
We've built Fletch to have a
wire protocol for doing program
changes in an atomic way.
So that means that you
can change multiple things
in your app and then
apply them in one go.
Sometimes you're
changing some things
in one method that
depends on other changes
to be live at the same time, so
you can bundle them up and then
apply them in an atomic
way over a wire protocol.
And this extends to
basically all the things
you might change in a program.
You can change the
superclass hierarchy,
add new fields to classes,
add new methods, of course,
and mess with the
implementations
of these things.
It just gives you
a very fluid way,
and one way of thinking
of this is it's
a very, very powerful debugger.
It's really a compelling
thing to have.
This is a known thing from
other languages and the systems,
and we're just trying
to bring that technology
to Dart as well, even in a
setting where you're running
your development environment
on one machine and your system
on a mobile phone.
The third thing
that we're doing,
which is a bit more
sort of experimental,
is the work on isolates that
makes us sort of even more
concurrent than we are today.
We're experimenting with
making it a lot cheaper
to do blocking operations,
because they're conceptually
a lot simpler than
the async limitations.
But it has to be
really, really cheap
so you don't get scalability
issues out of that.
Another thing that
we've made work
here is that it actually scales
to 100,000 concurrent isolates.
And we've done this by being
really, really aggressive
in how much we can share
between these isolates
and have them start out
really, really small.
So if you're doing like
just a few computations,
like one example here was let's
block on some database query,
then basically you're
not doing a lot of work
on that isolate so the
overhead can be really small.
An isolate starts out
being around 4K of memory,
and that includes the optic
heap and a small stack
for the execution, and
then it grows from there.
And the trick is, of course,
to share all the program
structures, all the classes,
all the byte codes between all
the isolates that run the
same sort of code base,
you could say, and just only
pay for the differences.
So how does it all fit in?
Let's focus on the iOS case.
On iOS, you might have
a lot of native code
that uses native
widgets, and you
might have some Dart
code in the mix as well.
Underneath that
thing there, there
is this Fletch
runtime that runs it,
and on your development
machine that
might be a little bit weird
to use a Linux machine up
against an iOS device, but
let's assume that works well.
You have your SDK that allows
you to debug, inspect, modify
code as it's running.
And the sort of thing
I point out here
is the sort of the
wire protocol allows
us to interact with the runtime,
change things, and inspect
the state and work
with the code, sort
of a really powerful debugging
interface, you could say.
So if we dive into what
this SDK might turn into,
this is a little bit sort of
up in the air in the sense
that this is a preview of what
we might actually put in there.
So it's a little bit
of a vision thing.
But I just want to give you
a feel for how this thing
actually might play out.
At the core of it,
we want to make sure
that we have great command line
tools for working with Dart
code, and we feel like
focusing on command line
first is a nice place to start.
It allows us to
sort of formulate
the concepts and the
things you work with,
and then sort of
build from there.
So this is probably going
to look a little bit
like an interactive
debug in many ways.
So we imagine that
having a way of running
Dart code through a tool
like this, starting it
up maybe on the device or
maybe on a local setting,
would feel pretty
natural to most people.
Of course, you can
set breakpoints
in your code and interact
with it through that.
Imagine you set a breakpoint
in an updateDisplay method,
and you hit that breakpoint,
an isolate pauses,
and you can see in the command
line here in this output
that you're paused at a
specific expression in there.
This is just like a
debugger, you could say.
So what happens if you
realize that there actually
is a small bug here or something
you'd like to play with?
And maybe this code is not
exactly what it should be.
You can step
through and actually
sort of understand why it's not
doing what you expect it to do.
For instance, if you debug and
step to the next statement,
you might see that
the state changes.
Like the x plus position
variable here changes its value
from null to 20 in this case.
Maybe that's not what
you were expecting.
Maybe it should've
been something else.
So if you wanted to fix
a number in here and say,
that number's not
entirely correct.
I want to update
that to 100 instead,
for instance, you
would just go edit
that in your favorite
editor, and the system
would realize that
you'd done a change
and tell you about that when
you start applying them.
So it might look
something like this.
Like we can tell that you've
updated this 10 to 100.
We can apply all these
changes to the running system
in an atomic operation,
and we can actually
tell you exactly what we're
doing to which methods and just
apply it and make it happen.
Once you've changed
code over there,
you may want to
restart the method
and start over and do
the computations again,
if that's safe.
And let's assume that
it is, so you just
rewind the method and
start stepping through it.
Now it's a plus 100 instead,
so it behaves a little bit
differently.
So you get 110 out
instead of the 20.
And assuming that
was what you wanted,
you've updated your code,
and you learned something
about how it works in practice.
And updating is actually
an interesting part,
but also this notion of working
with the code in a live setting
is really powerful.
It gives you better insight
into how it's actually behaving.
And just feeling comfortable,
just trying things out,
is really powerful.
You can, of course,
debug even more,
delete breakpoints, and
resume, and off you go.
So this is just to illustrate
how this atomic application
of changes could work out.
We will keep track
of what you changed,
and we will allow
you to update them
in one go over a wire protocol.
So Fletch as a
runtime system for iOS
is something we really
want you to get out
to you so you can start
building things that
run on iOS in a nice way.
So we're working very hard on
getting an early version of it
ready in Q3 so that it's ready
for proper feedback from you
guys.
And then we want a productize
it and make it into a real thing
that you can depend
on later this year.
It's only part of the
story, because having
a way of running
Dart code on mobile
is exciting-- at
least to some of us--
but we also need to figure out
what do you then build on top
and how do we make
all that fit together.
So there's something
missing here.
Just after we have
the runtime system,
we need to start building
real applications.
I'm going to dive into
how we see that happening.
We call that Dart for mobile.
In the iOS case, we
considered building this
on top of the runtime.
And we have some guiding
principles in this space.
We want to have a nice
layered approach where
we make use of existing
native functionality.
We want to keep it
low-level, fast, and simple.
And we want to try
to avoid enforcing
too many abstractions.
So we want to make sure that
if the abstractions that we
provide are not entirely
correct for what you're doing,
there's a lower level
you can go to and build
your own frameworks
on top instead.
So it's an attempt to make
sort of a layer of offerings
here where if the highest level
of abstraction that we offer
is slightly wrong for you, there
is a layer below you can go to.
I'm going to give you examples
of what these layers might
look like, and maybe that makes
it a little bit more concrete.
But this is the guiding
principles of what we're doing.
So the way we interact or
interoperate with native code
is through a sort of
cross-language support
based on a structured
messaging mechanism.
So imagine you have UI code
for Android written in Java,
and you have some UI code for
iOS written in Objective C,
and you have, hopefully,
lots and lots of Dart code
that are exposing a number
of services to this UI code,
we're building
support for allowing
you to access all these services
in a low-level, but fairly sane
way.
So the way it looks
is that you have
a description of a service, and
it's in sort of a low-level IDL
format.
In this case, there
is an echo service
that has a simple echo method.
You can see that it's
actually describing
how many bits these
integers are going
to take up in the protocol.
So it's designed to
be fairly low-level
so you can tweak it and
make things very compact.
On the Dart side, if you want
to implement this service,
it's fairly straightforward.
You just go ahead and
implement the echo method,
and in this case just
return the integer.
The interesting part is
really on the client side.
We're generating code to
make all this fit together,
and we're generating
steps for C++--
it works well in the
Objective C case, too--
that allows you to call these
methods as static methods.
And you can choose if
you want to call them
in a synchronous way or
you wait for the result.
In a lot cases, that's
the simplest version.
But there are also cases
if you're doing work
from a UI thread,
that it really doesn't
work for you to block and wait.
So we allow you to call
these things in an async way,
too, and get a callback
when the things are done.
In C++ there is no built-in
support for futures or promises
or even async in a way, so here
it's back to somewhat annoying
callbacks.
It's low-level, and we do
imagine the people will
build something on top.
It's really fast,
though, and I think
that's the core point here.
It's low-level and fast, and
it's fairly simple to extend.
Like, the Java version
is somewhat similar.
The biggest difference is in
the async case where you're not
passing a function
reference but some sort
of an instance of an interface.
So that's sort of how
we, at the lowest level,
imagine binding things together.
Clearly just passing
integers back and forth
is not that interesting.
You can do things with that,
but it's a little bit limiting,
so we do allow you to have
more structured messages.
So there a format for
describing these structures,
and they can have
fields, and they
can have basically entire
trees of structures
that you can build.
And you can serialize
them into a binary form,
and that's the one
we send across.
And the reason why
we're doing this,
even though it feels maybe
annoying to have to write this
and a bit cumbersome
to use, is that we
want these languages to have
a shared understanding of what
they're interacting over
and what kind of data types
flow between them.
So in this case,
you can see that you
can build an entire tree of
persons, like a hierarchy,
here with the children list.
And then you might
actually send a reference
to sort of a structure of
these things across the wire
and get a count of all the
people or persons in a tree
bank.
Everything runs in
the same process
in this model, which makes a
lot of things a lot simpler.
So the messages that
we send are actually
encoded as binary data.
We don't do any sort of
expensive encoding or decoding.
We're not producing a
tree of Dart objects
that you walk
through afterwards.
We're actually basically
just deconstructing
this binary thing as you
work with the structure.
So if there are areas you never
touch in that binary message,
it costs nothing.
And this is in
contrast with JSON
or even protobufs
where you usually
build up a Dart representation
of the entire message
and then start looking into it.
So really the binary
data that you send across
is the primary thing.
Again, low-level,
but very efficient.
The reason why everything
runs through the same process
is that we allow the
native application
to be in control
of this process.
It's the one invoking
all the Dart services.
We just link it into the
same application and the Dart
runtime.
In many ways, it
doesn't really--
it's just an implementation
detail, like your native app,
that you've decided to include a
runtime that runs on Dart code,
too.
It's very simple.
So I'd like to try to
show you a demo of what
we can do with this
thing on an iPad, so let
me try to switch to that.
So we've built a
small sample here.
It runs on Dart on top
of a Fletch runtime,
and it talks to
some GitHub APIs,
and it shows you a list of
GitHub commits for the Fletch
project.
Let me fire it up.
So one of the hardest
things you do in this space
is these infinite
scrolling lists of whatnot.
So you have basically a lot
of data inside the Dart model,
and you want to show a
part of it, a view of it,
and you want to update that view
as you scroll through the thing
here.
So all the data you have
in here are actually
stored in the Dart
side of the world,
and it's super smooth and sort
of a real native widget thing.
There is even sort of
a pagination going on
that we will fetch
things in the background
when we feel like we're
getting close to the limit
and fill in more data.
All that stuff happens
on the Dart side.
And the only thing that
we then communicate
from the Dart part of the
world to the native part--
in this case, the iOS
version-- is the thing
you can see on the screen.
So we can scroll back and forth,
and you can come play with it
afterwards.
It's a fairly simple
thing, but it just
shows that you
can take something
that involves talking to
a server written in Dart
and expose it to native code
in a fairly efficient way.
Like Fletch is not
the fastest system
in the world in the sense that
it's doing pure interpretation
on this device.
But, I mean, in a
lot of cases, it's
certainly fast enough to
build these real things.
So it looks pretty
promising to that extent.
And we can continue
scrolling here,
and it will just fill
in more information.
It builds up fairly
large structures quickly,
but it looks pretty good.
Does that makes sense?
Let's talk a little bit about
how that's actually built.
So it's sort of an infinite
GitHub commit list.
We showed them with
native widgets.
And the way we plug all
these things together
is using, at the lowest level,
this service description
that we then build
things on top of.
So in this case, we've
decided to build a layer
on top of the services that
have sort of a reactant spider
or a sort of
unidrectional flow model
for showing parts of a
Dart model in a native UI.
The way it actually
works is fairly simple,
at least in the abstract.
You have a Dart model that
defines a presentation graph,
and in this case, the
presentation graph
is what's actually
shown on the device.
So it's not everything.
It's the subset
that you can see.
That is a presentation
that then is interpreted
by the native UI, turned into
native widgets, you can say,
and if the native UI determines
that you are doing something
to some of these elements,
it will delegate it then back
to the presentation, and these
events will then potentially
update state inside the
model like telling the system
that you've scrolled.
So it feels like a
fairly nice model for it,
because it decouples the
Dart model from the native UI
in a very clean and sane way.
All they sort of interact with
is this presentation stuff,
and they do it in a
very orderly manner
by letting sort
of everything flow
in a sort of unidirectional way.
I'm not expecting you
can actually read this.
I'll go into detail so
you can see it later.
Don't worry too much about
it, but basically you
have a Dart model on
the side with Dart code.
You have a presentation
in the middle,
which is a small language for
defining this presentation
graph.
And then there is native
iOS code on the right side
here for constructing real
table views and cells for those
and delegating events back.
So if we start at the
presentation level here,
let's talk about what that thing
is and how we can define it.
As I said, it is defined on
top of the service description
that we've built, but we've
found that it's actually
kind of nice to be able to
introduce this notion of nodes
in this presentation graph.
These are application-specific
data type, you could say,
and in this case, it corresponds
to a list of commits.
That is, like the visible
stuff, and as some
of these commit nodes with
an author and a message
and a way of sending back,
delegating events back
into the system, in this
case, by clicking something,
for instance.
So you can write this
for your application,
write the data type that
makes sense for you,
and you can create this
from the Dart side then.
And let's take a look
at how that might look.
The Dart model
will actually find
some way of fetching
information from the network
or building that
up, build a model,
and then basically have a method
called, in this case, percent,
that will return a node from
this presentation graph,
construct it like
flux and react.
On demand you create
this list node
with some commits
in there, and then
the system actually will
look at the last presentation
graph you sent across
to the other side,
do a diff of those two
things, and only send
a patch set across the wire.
And we do this for
you by if you use
this kind of way of defining
a presentation graph,
we give you the
diffing algorithms
and all that for free.
So all you have to do is
basically think about,
in the abstract
terms, what things
constitute my presentation.
And then, of course, you
have to write the code, too.
But actually it takes
the presentation
and turns it into real
native UI widgets.
You could imagine building
like a more generic set
of presentation graph
nodes and then sharing
some of the native code
across multiple applications
if that make sense to you.
But it's kind of nice
to think of this model
as it allows you to have
application-specific
presentations that you then
write a bit of, in this case,
Objective C code for mapping
to the native widgets.
And the nice thing is that
we'll give you a patch set
and tell you what's changed,
what's been updated so you only
modify those things.
So basically you just
run through whatever
we tell you has
changed, not everything.
And that's the reason why it
actually works so smoothly
and it works so well.
And if you have questions
about this thing,
Ian is in the
audience, and he'll
be happy to-- he's
raising his hand here.
At least the people in the
room have an opportunity
to hunt him down afterwards
and learn more about this set
up we're building.
It is layered, so you
will find that anything
you describe in the
presentation graph description,
if we go back to that
in here, is actually
compiled into a set
of services that you
access across the wire.
And the definition for
the structured messages
that are involved in sending
these binary patches across
are these patch sets.
And that's a reason
why we think it's
nice to have a layered approach.
If something below this
level makes more sense,
then you can certainly
skip this and just
interact with the runtime
in that way instead.
So here's the model again.
You see one thing I
didn't really mention
is there's some hookup
here that tells you what
to do when this is selected.
It's basically just like
pulling in a Dart method here.
But you're never calling the
select method from in here.
That gets called through a
delegate event delegation
mechanism.
So the roadmap is
relatively simple.
I told you that we are
going to ship Fletch first,
and then we are going
to ship Dart for mobile
at the end of the year.
And Dart for mobile is
sort of the combination
of the runtime support for
actually making this run
on a device like you saw.
It's a service description layer
that is, this low-level thing.
And then there's a slightly
more opinionated way
of expressing
presentation graphs
and working with them
from the two sides.
Hopefully this sort
of makes sense to you.
It's a very practical approach.
It's a very low-level
approach, but it's
something that fits really
well into existing apps
and works well in order for
us to have a native story that
gives you real native
applications mostly,
or partly, written in Dart.
That's it.
KEVIN: We have time for maybe
one question that's short.
I scared them.
I have a question.
Anyone?
KASPER LUND: Shoot, Kevin.
KEVIN: How does your
definition format
relate to things like
protobuf or other things?
Like just the--
KASPER LUND: IDL.
KEVIN: --IDL format?
KASPER LUND: So if you're
talking about the lowest level,
like the service
description level,
it's in many ways inspired
by protobufs and systems
like Cap'n Proto.
We've simplified
it a little bit,
because we're running
in the same process
so we're not worried about
version skews at all.
So carrying around the weight
of having a protocol that
guarantees forwards and
backwards compatibility
is not necessary in our case.
So it's, you could say,
a simplified version
of mostly Cap'n Proto.
KEVIN: So it's not
designed for persistence
or over to the network?
KASPER LUND: It's designed
for really fast communications
between these two things
that are versioned together.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: As usual, if you
have more questions for Kasper,
he'll be around.
Bug him later.
I totally killed
the applause there
by talking right when
everyone was about to start.
KEVIN: For Kasper?
MALE SPEAKER: A
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]